ame
分
皆さんは1日3食の食事の中でその食材を育ててくれた人の顔を思い浮かべることは
ありますか
残念ながら画面越しにいる皆さんの表情は僕は確認はできません
しかし
大半の皆さんは首を横に振り
苦い顔をするんじゃないでしょうか
食材
それは僕たちにとって生きる上で欠かせないものです
だからお金さえ払えば誰もが手に入れることができます
食材が僕達の目の前にあることは当たり前ですよね
では
その食材一体どこからやってくるのでしょうか
牛の肉は人間と同じように2足方向をして僕達のもとにやって来るのでしょうか
キャベツやレタスはスーパーの陳列棚や冷蔵庫から勝手に生えてくるのでしょうか
違いますよね少なくとも僕は現実世界でそのような合計を一切3
たことはありませんもし見たことがある人がいるのであればこの動画を見るのをやめて
すぐ北に連絡をしてほしいです
それはさておき
食材はどこからやってくるのか生産者
そう
食材の原点には必ず生産者の方がいるのです
でも
僕たちは生産者のことを意識しながら買い物をしたり食事をすることは残念ながら
少ないでしょう
それも仕方ありません
生産者の方が直接お肉やお魚お野菜を販売することが少なければ
商品ポップにもでっかく書かれた
商品名値段そして小さく書かれた
生産地
これぐらいしか見ることができません生産者のことを考える環境は日常生活の中には
ほとんど存在しないのです
でも生産者が食事の原点にいることには何ら変わりはありません
そして僕たちがそれを意識することで日本の農業を懸命に支えてくださっている生産者
の方に放棄なパワーを授けることができると僕は信じています
その結果僕たちは心が満たされるような素敵な食事を実現することができると思うの
です
だから
今日は皆さんに僕が今まで訪れてきた
農業現場をいくつか紹介しその生産者の思いを届けます
そしてみんなで日本の農業を元気づけ
素敵な食事を実現するために一緒にアクションを起こしていくきっかけとしていきたい
と思いますチョッパから熱く語ってしまいましたが
自己紹介
はまだでしたね
僕は都内の大学に通う大学4年生です
普段は教育学について研究していて子どもが安心して過ごせる居場所は
探求学習について学びを深めています
食や農業に関する研究は一切行なっておりませんじゃー
なぜ今日僕は日本の農業や食について語ろうと思っているのかそれはサークルで農業に
勤しんできたからです僕は大学三年が終わるまでの大半の時間を
農業をすることに費やしていました現在は引退した身ではありますが
田や畑を耕し農作物を育てたり
e 日本の地域を訪れた
にしていました北は岩手南は高知おいた
それはもうあらゆる地域であらゆる人にお世話になっていました
その一環で僕は岩手の山奥にある牧場で10日間ほど研修をしたことがあります
その牧場は牛舎がなく東京ドーム約23戸
分の芝生の上で牛たちが気ままに過ごしていました
牛は大半の時間をその芝生の上で過ごしているんですが
屋内に入るときももちろんありますそれは牛の乳を搾る時ですそのとき人間の出番が
やってきます
僕は研修生とはいえども社員の方と同じように牛のお世話をしていきました
牧場の朝はとても早く朝6時前から作業が始まります
つまり起きるのは朝の5時
眠たい目をこすりながら重たい体をどうにか持ち上げながら広大な土地に広がる
牛たちを搾乳場にかき集めた移住後600キロの巨体を気ままにいらしながら過ごして
いる
牛を優しくなだめながらみるかーという機械で搾乳をしていきましたこのさ
量を繰り返すこと約5時間弱ようやく汗の作業が終わります
そして昼休憩を少しだけハサミお昼過ぎも同様の作業を行ってもう日が暮れた頃には
完全に体がクタクタです
でもその後に味丸晩御飯の時間はを至福の時間でした
僕は晩御飯の時間に毎日そこの牧場で作られた乳製品をいただいていました
そこでいただいた柔乳やバターはとても美味しかったです
牛乳は味の濃さが一貫していて舌触りも滑らかでした
バターに関しては
皆さんはバターをそのまま食べるという経験はあまりないとは思うんですが僕はそこの
バターをご飯の上に乗っけて前につ食べてました
もう僕のスター唸っていました
同時に僕のお腹もうなりお腹を壊してしまいました
でもそのお腹を壊した後でも食べたいと思ってしまうぐらいに僕はその乳製品に夢中に
なってしまいました
作業はもちろん大変でしたがその大変な作業を上げて
できる乳製品はここまでうまいのかと身をもって痛感しました
僕は生まれつき不器用な人間です
なんで中学の西方の時間も万年し評価でした
最低評価ですねなので牧場で作業をする時にも些細なミスを繰り返してを社員の方に
こっぴどく叱られていました
でもそんな中でも僕は大切なことを学びました
社員の方が僕を叱る中でいつもおっしゃっていたことが今でも印象に残っていますそれ
は
牛も人間と同じ行きも
だから牛がどう思ってるか想像しながら作業をしてほしい
ということです
僕は驚きましたそれまでの僕は
牛は乳製品を生産し利益を生み出すだけの
経済動物だと思っていました生産者の方ももちろんそう思っていると思いました
でも違ったのです
牛は経済動物であると同時に1等えっと愛情が込められ
丁寧に飼育される
生き物
であると
僕はそこで痛感したのですこの想いがあるからこそこの牧場で作られる乳製品は
非常に美味しいものがあったんでしょう
そして普段僕たちが飲んでいる牛乳
食べている色ヨーグルトもきっと数々の生産者の思いが込められているにちがいがあり
ません
農家というには経験が物足りないですが僕もつい最近までは農業を実践する一人の生産
者でした
大学の農業サークルでお米を中心になすトマトトウモロコシ落下せ
などなどそれはもういろんな作物を作ってきました
農業分野ではよく人手不足が騒がれていることは聞いたことがあると思いますしかし僕
の農業サークルは最大6種12
これを簡単に表すと僕たちの田んぼや畑が人数で丸々埋まってしまうほどの人数に
恵まれていて人手不足に悩まされることはありませんでした
農作業時際はキョン的に楽にできていたと思っています
しかしだからといっていつも成功するとは限りませんでした
例えば
毎年67キロ収穫できていたお米が昨年はなんと全滅してしまったのです
これは立て続けになってきた台風によって一音に負担がかかりさらに
例年より多く発生してしまったスズメに稲穂をついばまれてしまったことに原因がある
でしょう
僕は見るに耐えない姿になってしまった犬の姿を見てとてもショックを受けました
また毎年収穫祭というイベントで収穫できたお米を調理してみんなで食べるのですが
その収穫できたお米を使わずに調理をしたのでとても寂しい思いでイベントが始まって
しまいました
ob og にも顔向けができませんでしたあ
なんて言っていいのかわかりませんでした
でも僕は同時に大切なことを学びました
それは食べ物の存在は当たり前ではないということです
ここまでつらく重い話ばかりをしてきてしまったかと思います
でももちろん農業をしていく中で楽しい思い出もたくさんありました
その一つが収穫できたお米を使って近くの幼稚園の子どもたちにおにぎりを振る舞った
時です
幼稚園の子供たちは笑顔でこういう言葉を僕に投げかけてくれるのです
美味しい
もっと食べたい
その言葉を聞いて僕は&と感動に包まれました
作って良かったなぁ
よし来年もがんばって作るぞ
そんな気持ちに右が包まれました農業をしていなくてもこれに似たようなの経験をみな
さんはしてるんじゃないでしょうか
例えば誰かに料理をふるまってとっても美味しいと言われたとき
大切な人にプレゼントを渡してありがとう
とても嬉しいと言われた時その時に嬉しそうな顔を見たり
素敵な言葉を投げかけてもらった時皆さんもやりがいを感じませんか
それと同じ気持ちです
生産者の方もきっと消費者の方からそういった気持ちを受け取ってやりがいを感じたい
と思っているのではないでしょうか
生産者はすべてた作物を誰が手にとってくれるか分からない中
人生をかけて作物を育てていますしかしここ最近は異常気象による
大雨で作物がすべて流されてしまったり
今年なんか新型コロナウイルスの影響で作物を下ろしても全然売れなかったりとしねえ
できなく今日 new 立たされていることが増えています
そんな時だからこそそういう者が生産者のことについて考えることが大事になってきて
いるのです
生産者が何のそしてどのような思いで
作物を育てているのか考えることこそ消費者と生産者をつなげる
第一歩となり得るのですでもそんなこと言われてもどう考えればいいんだよ
と言われる方も画面越しにたくさんいるんじゃないかと思っています
そんな方のために今日は生産者について考えるツールを2つ紹介したいと思います
まず1点目やインターネット通販です
ここ最近はインターネットを介して直接農作物を得る生産者の方も実は増えてきてい
ます
しかもただその作物を売るだけではなくて
こだわりやおいしい食べ方など消費者が作物や生産者を身近に感じられるような紹介文
が添えてあったにチャットに乗って生産者とコミュニケーション
[ __ ]が取れるサービスを備えているものもあります僕も実際にインターネット通販を
通して作物を買って実食することがありますそこで買った作物は生産者の思いが味覚に
もしっかり伝わっているのか
いつも食べている食べ物よりも
10倍の数倍もおいしく感じられるのです
そしてその思いをチャットに乗せて生産者の方に伝えるとそれはもう元気づけられると
言ってくれるのです
そして2つめは農業を実際に実践してみることですマリオよく見渡してみると大きな畑
そして小さな畑が点在しているのではないかと思います
それを見つけた皆さんは生産者について実際に体を動かして考えてみるチャンスです
実際にその畑を契約してみてください
もちろん毎日働かれている社会人の方毎日学業に宗主までという学生の方毎日皆さんが
いろんな
ことをして頑張っていますなので前にで農業をすることは難しい方が多いかもしれませ
ん
でも大丈夫週末農業というやり方があります
これは名前の通りお休みの日だけ農業に関わることができるシステムです
ぜひそういうシステムを取り入れている畑を契約してみてください
でも
そもそも畑が全くない地域に住まれている方もいると思います
そういう形でも農業を実践できるんですまず
プランターと肥沃な土そして自分が育てない作物の種を買ってきてください
磯してプランターの中によーくナッツと作物の種を入れて自分の家の庭
もしくはベランダ
に設置してみてくださいこれであなたも立派な生産者の一人です
ただ簡単にうまく育てられるとは断言できません
先ほども言ったように農業にはトラブルがつきものです
短杖を込めて水をあげていた作物愛情を込めて育てていた作物が突然見るに耐えない姿
になってしまうことも
現実的にはあり得るのですでもだからこそ身を守って学べることがありますそれは
食べ物を存在は当たり前ではない
食べものの原点にはいつも生産者がいることです
そしてこんな辛い出来事を乗り越えて実際に新しく作物を育て直し
収穫のできた食べ物は普段皆さんが食べている食べ物より何倍も何倍もおいしくなるに
違いありませんさて皆さんは普段食べている
食べ物についてどのような感情を抱いたでしょうか
何度も言いますが食べ物はその原点に生産者がいるからこそ成り立っているのです
僕の話を聞いてこれから意識的に食べ物に接することができそうと思った方今日の
ごはんからきっと味が変わるに違いありません
まだまだ実感できないなぁちょっと思った方でも大丈夫
これからあらゆる観点で食べ物を合成していくなかで消費者のあなたと生産者が
つながる瞬間は必ずやってきます
一緒に消費のあり方を考え直し消費者も生産者も生き生きとした食卓をつくっていき
ましょう